from timcast.com Elon Musk tweets video
entering Twitter headquarters updates
bio to Chief twit as deal nears closing
this is huge let me let's see if I can
uh you can't really see the video it's
very small
but it's just uh Elon Musk laughing as
he carries a sink into Twitter
and he says entering Twitter HQ let that
sink in
now I get it wow he's the cheesiest dad
jokes man but he earned it so he's not
throwing the kitchen sink at it this is
about let it sink in this is all for
that all for the joke I guess or is he
gonna wash the wash the dishes are you
going to clean the place up I mean is it
all these he's gonna fire 75 percent of
the staff did you see the demands they
sent a demand they're ludicrous but they
was like they weren't asking him to do
stuff they were just demanding that he
does they were low with the demands
don't fire us it was really yeah I was
like let us work from home I think don't
be racist don't be racist was one of
them don't stop us from working from
home don't be politically biased that
was my favorite one oh wow see that's
exactly what it is Colin Wright tweeted
this he was like it's going to be funny
when all the woke left flip and now
support or I now demand the government
intervene to stop private companies from
setting their own rules demand
preservance of benefits
um demand leadership and sure Fair
Severance for all workers
uh demand transparent prompt thoughtful
communication around the working
conditions some of these you would think
he's going to do anyway but as soon as
you start demanding of your owner like
well you should probably you know you
should do he should turn off Twitter
from like
I don't know what like five to seven
every night he just just turns it off
and it's like everybody you have to
watch something else you can't use
Twitter don't read a book go read a book
yeah he turns it off for two hours calm
down everybody go on and then everyone
just starts like shaking and they're
getting ah no if he did that they just
go to Instagram or something yeah they
demand that he preserves the current
head count they demand that he doesn't
fire them what in the heck you know what
I'm really jealous of Elon Musk you know
why
because he gets to fire these people
like just imagine how much fun that
would be no no for everybody doesn't
imagine you're Elon and you walk into
Twitter HQ and you get to walk through
the whole building you can you're a
billionaire so you can fly in a private
jet to any one of your satellite offices
and you get to walk through and just
look someone right in the eye and go you
get out
that's lucky you know these people
making the demands I mean what were what
were their home lives like when they
were kids were they making demands of
their parents or their parents yes you
know just fully saying
sure I probably yeah right I mean we see
lots of parents doing that snowplow
parenting when the parents bulldoze
everything out of the path of the kid so
these these kids grew up with no
obstacles and they expect to be handed
everything that's why they're confused
the government isn't just giving them
free food it's why they say things like
there's more empty houses than homeless
people so let's just put them in the
empty houses and then you're like hey do
you know what one plus one equals like
you put up you put you put a mentally
ill person in a house how long until the
house burns down falls apart who's
supporting or sustaining who's paying
taxes who's funding it who's going to
cover the cost of the fire department
these people don't think these things
through and it's because their parents
walk them through everything without
giving them any obstacles and
participation trophies everywhere they
go five things elon's talked about is uh
not letting people remote into work as
much and I I worked social media and I
found like that was the best part of the
job was being able to work from home at
my on my own time limit and we didn't
have to be in the office together so it
it was like and then we actually we got
an office in Brooklyn and it was just an
expenditure we didn't need it we found
out after a year we're like why do we
even have this thing we don't need it so
I I don't know I hope that he's open to
letting people work remote but he thinks
that I think what he said is that unless
if the people aren't there to have
oversight over that they don't work
properly and that might be a good
argument
why why let people work remote I mean I
I understand there's some circumstances
where it's probably fine but most people
probably shouldn't commuting is is
lengthy it's time consuming and
expensive too bad and so is having an
office if you don't need one if you
don't want to be here you probably
shouldn't be
that's what I always say so when you
know if there's somebody who's like man
I want to work with a company but I'd
rather not be there I'll be like well
then you're not going to work here I
don't get it like you want people who
who are passionate about the project
they're working on like um oh yeah for
sure for sure so right now you have
Millennials and gen Z quiet quitting
have you guys heard of this yeah yeah
they're basically like it's a
combination of ideas one way I've heard
it described when they're trying to make
it you know politically correct is it's
not not working it's just doing exactly
what you're asked and it's like okay
well that's nothing that's called doing
your job what we're saying is don't go
above and beyond it's like okay yeah
well you know no one's making you do
that some might ask you but if you don't
want to fine but typically quiet
quitting was referring to people who are
quitting working without saying anything
to keep getting paid as long as possible
until they got fired that's the
mentality of these people so
that's what's happening right now at
Twitter a good majority of people work
there probably do not do work wasn't
that the Veritas thing that that audio
or someone's like I work four hours a
week
this is going to be very exciting I'm
I'm I'm optimistic about this I'm
skeptical because the man still wants to
sell robots and put brain chips inside
of your your skull but at the same time
he did tweet today that he's quote a big
fan of Citizen journalism he also
tweeted how citizen journalism is
dismantling The Establishment bias and
then went on a tirade and went as far as
to even call the New York Times a quote
chaotic actor causing problems in our
society so uh he didn't say that exactly
he said that uh you know just in the
general sense of what he was saying here
so so I'm excited for what he's going to
be doing I'm excited for the
opportunities that are going to be
presented because he's he's essentially
promising free speech he's essentially
saying Hey The Establishment has gotten
it wrong a lot of people have been
censored before we need free speech more
than ever I'm willing to put billions of
dollars into this what's going to be the
result of this I don't know I I hope
it's going to at least help mend a lot
of the bigger problems in our society
because I think it can because the
larger provide and Conquer agenda that
has been pushed on everyone the larger
disinformation the larger censorship
efforts have been causing a net negative
towards our society you could solve all
of that just by allowing people to talk
freely and with him already cheering on
citizen journalism independent
journalism trying to of course promote
people who are trying to hold big Powers
accountable highlights how this could
potentially be something that could be
amazing and world's changing yeah I
think that what one of the things that
will happen is that Twitter uh parlor
when Kanye buys parlor and mines with
Bill ottman's minds are going to
Federate and interoperate start to
interoperate along with Rumble Chris
pavlovsky's Rumble which is already
working with starlink to uh Interlink
their servers and starlinks networking
capabilities to get Global Internet
um and actually
solar internet like we're gonna have a
planet to planet interplanetary internet
and you have all these networks start to
be able to interoperate Jack Dorsey
wants Twitter to be a protocol meaning
that you're unbannable it's
decentralized everybody can post no one
has control over what you say and the
only thing that happens if it's illegal
then the police can deal with it
if Elon Musk does implement that we know
that Jack Dorsey was talking with him
behind the scenes before he decided to
buy this that is a strong possibility
Elon does move towards making it a
protocol it does then merge in a sense
with with Minds as a node or with Rumble
gab uh um parlor truth social even and
then the way it would work is and this
is the way it absolutely should be
you have a Twitter account
it's Twitter servers so they could they
could ban you on their server but if you
turn it into a protocol your username
goes onto whichever server you want it
to be on so if you're using gab servers
you know they're not going to ban you
unless you dock someone or violate or
break the law so you're like I'd rather
be hosted there but I'm on Twitter I can
follow Ian gab.com and then I get Ian's
tweets on Twitter even though he's
posting on Geb and Twitter has no say in
it it's almost like reverse RSS I
suppose it could be that's the way it
should be he's also talking about
allowing end-to-end encryption when it
comes to private messages and as an
independent content creator as an
independent journalist I'm going to
pretty much go all in I'm going to
invest in my time and I think this is
going to also move the market in a way
that that I think is worth talking about
because if you have a platform providing
Free Speech providing something that all
the other big big Tech social media
platforms aren't providing he's going to
push the needle he's going to be very
competitive in the market because now
Facebook Instagram all these other large
corporations uh Google YouTube are going
to be looking at at him like Hey we
can't hide the cat in the bag anymore
hey you know these ideas are still being
expressed they're not being censored
here the more we censor them the more
obvious it becomes because now on
Twitter we have a platform that of
course is allowing the truth to actually
get out there allowing real
conversations to get out there without
an algorithm without Bannings without
censorship without restrictions on
speech this is going to I think in my
opinion if this is done as Elon Musk
says he wants it to be done shift the
market in a net positive when it comes
to overall freedoms and speech yeah I
just gotta I gotta I gotta throw this
out there because I I I would be I have
to
Elon Musk Joe Rogan me let's talk about
Twitter's rules censorship it'll be the
Twitter the Twitter Rogan episode 2.0
I I obviously you know I'd love to make
that happen because I'm the lowest on
the totem pole of the of them Elon of
course the richest guy on the planet Joe
Rogan the biggest podcast in the plant
then the little old me so I'll I'll say
what you know hey come on guys like
let's let's get a show going
um I'd imagine they probably care very
little but I do think it would be really
epic to sit down and discuss twiners and
Twitter's internal policies plans bias
censorship imagine this if you guys
watched when I was on Joe Rogan this is
back in like 2019 with Vijay God and
Jack Dorsey and everything I said and
everything they said give Elon Musk a
month or two of actually going through
the internals
then sitting back down and saying okay
Elon which of what they said was true
and which of what they said was a lie
and then have Elon just be like oh they
said this that was a lie they said this
that was a lie and then to go through
policy procedure philosophy ideology
would be incredible but we're also we're
also going to find out what was I I
think this is a big possibility of
finding out how else was was Twitter
manipulated we're going to find out
about the Bots we're going to find out
what they were doing we're going to find
out about their algorithm we're going to
see what an uncontrolled social media
platform is unless the FBI doj and U.S
intelligence agencies come to Elon Musk
and kind of proverbly put the gun to him
and say hey you're going to do what we
want you to do look at this Drew
Hernandez says apparently leftists are
fleeing to this new Twitter alternative
called tribal social network wow dude
they've posted that they don't censor
they just have an algorithm that bans
bigotry it's like okay dude like
go for it I don't care I hate it so you
could say two plus two equals five
that's right all right I don't know
entertaining I want to piggyback off of
your idea from earlier Tim about being
able to log into your Twitter account
and follow me on mines for instance and
I think it'll even be better than that
in that you'll be able to lock you'll
basically your account will be your
wallet it'll be like your your crypto
wallet like a metamask account or
something like that and you'll log into
social networks with your wallet and
that will also help you bypass things
like PayPal or your bank Like A Banks
and things like that these these weird
like top-down authority figures trying
to eyeball your accounts
um and it'll it'll it'll create kind of
a
a parallel economy so to speak a
parallel culture yeah for sure it's like
the fist coming breaking out of the
ground of dirt you know it's it's
awesome thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at
8pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there